alright alright hello everyone how are
you doing good I hope there there's
still some more people coming in
probably getting out from the keynote I
really appreciate that you came here to
watch my talk I gonna talk about build a
powerful data back-end for mobile and
web a little bit about myself I'm a
cloud developer advocate so basically
I'm the interface between the people
that build the technology inside of
Google and people that build on the
technology outside of Google so
hopefully you guys and girls gonna take
something out of this talk and build
something amazing afterwards before I
start I want to get a little bit of a
feel who am I talking to
so who a few here is is a developer
alright that's amazing you're in the
right place who is an Android developer
who has done something with firebase
alright a lot back and back-end
developers anyone who develops with
coaling awesome awesome cool so my
favorite languages are golang and Java
so I gonna stick to Java and this talk
to reach some the most or the biggest
audience basically so let's get started
so if we choose at the right storage it
is is actually really really a big
problem this is really hard to do so we
have a lot of things to consider when
you choose your storage system so things
like what's the object size what's the
scale that you need what are the latency
requirements throughput consistencies
and like permissions things like that so
there are a lot of things that you need
to consider when choosing the right
storage system now when I created this
talk I was thinking like what am I going
to talk about or how do I gonna
construct this talk so I was wondering
if I should start with something oh I
have to get it out start like 20 years
ago pretty much right where you had like
storage systems which are mostly local
one thing
like that who still remember this right
I actually even started with the five
and a quarter soul and diskettes but
they are pretty amazing but I thought
like I'm not gonna bore you with like
history like 20 years ago even so it's
amazing it's really interesting and
everybody should look into that but we
are living in the now and almost in the
future so I gotta talk a little bit
about the things that you can do today
okay so how can I do that like I didn't
want to go through like a trite talk in
the sense of like talking you through
the different options that you have like
with firebase or with Google cloud
platform I wanted to make that a little
bit more entertaining so I thought about
let's let's do this and create an sample
app okay so here's my my startup idea
I'm a cloud developer advocate so for me
everything is about the cloud so my
startup idea is cloudy dot pictures so
concentrate on one thing and do one
thing well right this is where I want to
get to by the end of the talk I want to
have an app where you can upload
pictures right where you can crop and
resize the picture where you can store
metadata and then of course display the
date the pictures right so what do we
have in terms of options now I saw a
couple of you or firebase developers for
for the ones that haven't been for a
touched or have touched firebase so far
I really recommend to look into that
firebase gives you a lot of things a lot
of tools to build applications
especially mobile applications be it
like Android iOS or web application
right you have things like
authentication hosting firestore which
gives you a flexible data storage for
for metadata you have cloud storage for
firebase and you have even something
that can execute server-side code called
cloud functions for firebase now there
might be situations where where you have
to get out of this where you want to do
a little bit more sophisticated tasks
the things that you can't cover with
cloud function there are limitations
with cloud functions and there are
reasons to to break out of this
ecosystem so that's where Google cloud
platform comes in with Google cloud
platform you have
a multitude of tools at your disposal
that you can use on one hand you have
compute from like be rpms where you can
do pretty much everything that you want
almost up to cloud functions as well
right so you have a multitude of compute
that you can use to do your things we
also have a multitude of storage
products under the Google cloud platform
portfolio some of these products are
actually the exact same products that
you can use with firebase so you can
think of that you have different
interfaces to the same product which
makes it actually easier to deal with
them for sifl different use cases so if
you build a web app it's easier to use
the firebase SDK if you build a back-end
system you can use like our client
libraries for on the Google cloud
platform alright so the first thing when
we upload a picture we need a place to
store our pictures so that's where
Google Cloud Storage comes in or cloud
storage for firebase asset they're both
the same product the product is actually
a highly available Drupal simple and
secure object storage what does it mean
what is an object source so object
storage is pretty much every kind of
block that you can think of a plop is
basically bytes right so it can be
images it can be videos it can be normal
files it can pretty much be any byte
stream that you can find now cloud
storage is optimized for for user
latency for end user latency there are a
lot of things that you can do you can
define the caching strategies things
like that you can make your object
storage public so that people outside
can access you can actually make it in
the sense that other people pay for the
access to your cloud storage system it
is integrated with what our over 100
endpoints or cloud pops that we call so
basically if somebody comes in from
let's say Asia or Europe they go to the
closest pop 4 which is connected to
their Internet service provider and then
they go directly into our Google Network
and that means the latency to retrieve
objects or even store objects are live
minimized so it's a really good tool for
app that's exactly what we want any
right so we're gonna start with creating
a packet so a packet is a unique root
endpoint so to say that you have to
create to be able to store some some
data when you create a bucket you define
things like the storage class and the
location where your pocket lives so in
this case as you can see here I'm I have
two examples either you use our CLI
gsutil you make a bucket you define the
storage class in this case it's
multi-regional and then my storage is
cloudy to pick a cloudy - pictures you
can do the same with java if you want to
it so if you want to create buckets
programmatically you can use our storage
API s-- and then basically directly
created from your java program now next
step is uploading a file again very easy
if you're familiar with CP on any kind
of operating system you just prepend it
with cheese you at all - CM which allows
you to actually multicast your your your
upload and then you upload a picture
here to our cloud storage bucket in java
pretty much simple and straightforward
as well you select the file you point to
a file you make a byte stream out or
binary out of it you put it in the
bucket and create created with a name as
you can see here in this example i
actually also gave it the content type
that you can do as well if you want to
do it from web for the ones that have
done firebase this looks familiar
so basically you use the fireplace web
SDKs you get the storage reference you
use a file reader you get you from your
input field you get the file name and
the content and you upload that to
storage very straightforward that we use
as well for our app a next last but not
least for storage is how to read a file
and again it's very straightforward you
can do copy like downloaded you can use
Java the plop object and read it from
the from your pocket or on the web you
basically get a download URL and then
you use this download download URL and
put it in for instance your image tag or
your background
which CSS attribute all right so that's
great we uploaded all our pictures or we
uploaded one picture now how can I do
processing right if I upload a picture
from my phone or from like from my
camera
these pictures are large they are like
megabytes and I don't want to serve
megabytes of pictures always to to my
webpage or to my users Edward strain the
bandwidth a lot so what I want to do is
I want to actually create some
thumbnails now there's a possibility
that you create some nails already on
your clients but I don't think that is a
good idea there are many reasons for not
doing this now I can create some nails
on the back end which I going to use and
I could trigger the some decoration from
my clients I don't think that is a good
idea either what happens if you upload a
picture and then you get disconnected or
the some new creation fails and you need
to retry it all this logic would be
cluttering your your front-end and your
your client code you want to do these
things on the back end so I want to use
a different mechanism to actually
triggering the processing of my image
files and that's where object
notifications come in so object
notifications on Google Cloud Storage
allows you to basically register a hook
which gets called if anything happens on
your storage system so there are four
event types and you can hook your
systems up to its ISO finalized which is
basically object.create it's an object
delete it is archiving of an object and
it's any kind of metadata update that
you do on your objects so you can hook
into any of these events and there's
different mechanisms to hook into these
events there are three main mechanisms
that you can use on one end if you use
firebase and cloud functions you can use
the cloud storage trigger for cloud
functions so it basically if you submit
your function you can say these
functions get triggered if anything
happens on my bucket this is actually an
integrated with the cloud pub/sub
notification system so flower pops up
notification also allows you to set a
notification watch command
on your on your bucket and say if
anything happens of these events that I
declare please send me a pops up message
and then you can have a system that
deals with the pops up message and and
they're kind of the legacy object change
notifications that are still around is
to what we introduced fairly early on in
the Google Cloud storage platform a
storage product is the object change
notification so if you reduce the knob
check change notification you basically
get an HTTP call through an HTTP
endpoint and then you can deal with the
message there as well the nice thing
about this is all this what you're using
here if you set this up it's integrated
in the way that it does all the retry so
if you don't acknowledge a successful
processing of the message yet the system
just retries it automatically up to 30
days all right so how do I set up a
cloud pops up trigger here's an example
are using the G cloud pops up G Cloud
SDK or COI so it will G cloud pub/sub
topics create notice I the player a
notification I create here in this case
and notification against my cloudy
pictures bucket and I say I only want to
have notifications when object finalize
is happening so when an object is graded
and then I declare the public where this
notification is going to be sent to and
then if I want to have a system that
receives this messages I create a
so-called subscription
here at G cloud pops up subscription
grade pops up and not if not if sup
which basically hooks to the topic that
I just created all right so let me show
you how that looks like really quick so
I want to show you here you see my
application right now it's pretty empty
if i refresh this nothing is happening
so throughout this talk I actually want
to fill this with pictures so I can
assure you if I upload a picture here I
just select one picture icon it to
upload and it's gonna upload but pretty
much nothing else going to happen
alright so if I gonna refresh my page
this picture is actually gonna be gone
so I need to
and all the things behind the scenes to
process this picture so the first thing
that we're gonna do is we're gonna I
show you how to create this let me make
that a little bigger can you see this
thumbs up thumbs down if you can see
that alright cool
so first thing is g-cloud pops up and
then i so it's a topic great and let's
stay tuned no tips up oh that's right
alright so I create my not've topic
alright perfect that happened the next
thing that I gonna do is I want to
actually create my my watch command so
now if you have spotted I actually named
the topic differently so I gonna remove
this here and create this notification
so now what is going to happen is
actually I'm creating a not've and a
notification watch on my my storage
bucket you see here the storage is named
a little different because that is the
storage which I actually use for my
application now the next thing that I
want to do is I would actually want to
see if any messages are coming in so I
can do notification pops up sorry she
pops up notification
all right so it's subscription I just
created a subscription like I actually
need to create a subscription I haven't
done that so I want to create a
subscription which I call uploads create
a subscription so now I have a
subscription that actually listen
listens on that topic
this is a little slows and let me turn
off the Wi-Fi and hope that it works a
bit better without the Wi-Fi alright so
now I want to actually listen to my pops
up topic so I gonna do pops up
subscription and then I can pull and I
gonna pull and not connect knowledge but
I gonna pull on uploads right so as you
can see right now there's not nothing
kinda happening see your items so let me
upload a picture really quick again can
upload that picture and then gonna go
back to my system to pull uploads as you
can see here I have them have a message
alright in this message as you can see
there's a lot of things there are things
like the idea a self link for it name
the bucket generation ID all these
things that you can use alright so next
thing let's go back to the slides
so I've my my packet so now if I upload
my pictures and processing them I want
to actually store some data around this
so even if I now process my pictures I'm
not nothing gonna happen basically
they're not gonna be displayed in my web
page so I need something to actually
process them and and store some metadata
or anthem so that's where we go back and
look at like what is the portfolio of
systems that we have available for us
and here I gonna look at firestorm fire
store is a no SQL back-end system which
allows you to store document based data
and that the advantage of that is
actually that's very flexible in a sense
so if you want to add some some fields
or things that it said you can do that
that throughout the life cycle of the
application so you don't have to be very
restrictive on the
that you're gonna use you can just
evolve the schema value at develop your
application now for fire store again
they are a client libraries that you can
use from the web as well as from your
back-end systems so log fire starts just
to summarize again it's very flexible
you have an expressive query language in
three language you get real-time updates
if you use firebase you can basically
use watch commands or basically get
events for any data that has changed you
have offline support if you do a web
application and it's designed to scale
again so this is a system that can scale
to massive sizes so how do you write
data to fire store here's an example for
Java so pretty much everything in fire
store is a sink so as you can see here
you get the document ref you give it a
name to your document basically in an ID
we have a collection document and then
you put your fields in there to write
this is you use an API future and then
you can also update fields if you want
to now if you read data it's pretty much
similar to that there are not a lot of
changes here you just do on the document
ref that you create you just do a get
and that block still you have the data
all right so let's see how we can
integrate that to the actually write
some data in our application so now
we're going to switch to our to some
code so what I have here is my image
processing service so whatever here is I
basically set up my application with
Google credentials so this uses the
default credentials that you have set
either if you run that on a GC instance
compute engine instance then you have a
default context or you provide a service
account which is used to authenticate
you it's done very easily you really
need only this part like six lines to
get the storage condor - you get the
credential context now then we need a
project ID we define our storage that we
want to use so this is again cloud
storage for firebase I define here my
pops up that I have defined
and I can actually use this and say okay
I created a pops up which is uploads so
I can use the app the uploads
subscription that I created earlier
alright and then this code what you see
here is basically listening for pops up
messages so that's again doing this
asynchronously every time I get a
message I have here my message that I
get I gonna put that into my process
message function which we going to look
into in a bit and then if the function
is actually successful I acknowledge
this message now what you have if pops
up is if you can actually have multiple
subscribers on the same subscription and
what happens is your message get
round-robin distributed to all the typo
subscribers on one subscription now if
you want to make sure that one message
is distributed to multiple places and
always to multiple places then you just
create multiple subscriptions alright so
let's look into our process message so
what are we going to do here is
basically I gonna check for uploads on
my on my image when it gets uploaded and
I kind of show you really quick we have
here our storage system if I go to
storage you're gonna see here are some
images there are the two images that I
uploaded earlier so let me yeah alright
and then I basically take the pass take
the user ID out of this take the file ID
out of it do some resizing I'm doing the
resizing here with imagemagick so that's
the reason I wanted to run this on a
cheesy instance for instance I store the
sums in my pocket as you can see here in
the create function I have like a 600
pixel wide thumbnail and a 1600 pixel
white thumbnail and then I just create
and move this object as well to a
different folder that it's not in my
uploads folder anymore and last but not
least I just clean up all my my
temporary files that I had a head in
between so now as you can see I just
have started that so let's see what's
gonna happen
since we
uploaded some pictures earlier on this
on this subscription it should actually
get these as you can see now it actually
gets these messages and that's all the
processing right so let's have a look
how that looks like so we see here that
we have our messages we can say on my
storage you can see if anything is
happening okay we have actually uploads
and RAW images now so we have images
moving great amazing and then let's see
if any metadata is coming in Natal a is
not coming in alright so let's just
upload another picture and see if our
metadata is coming in actually I'm not
writing any metadata so I actually need
to write my metadata first so we need to
look into setting this up for writing
some metadata so the first thing is I
want to might have my fire story so fire
story in it so this creates takes the
credentials again and initializes my
firebase app and my fire store and the
next is before I move my data to the raw
folder actually let's do it by and
laughs after that I want to update my my
fire store metadata so here I'm just
going to add three fields the process
fields is some available fields and a
large available field alright they're
gonna save this on a restored my
application something is missing all
right fire verse is not there fire store
all right of course we need actually to
provide this here so a firestorm and
then here I want to provide my firestorm
all right
let's try this again alright so now it
is working so let's have a look if we
upload a picture okay you upload a
picture
so this is actually just a client site
that I display this picture so if i
refresh icon to see nothing that's okay
I can't see nothing because it's
basically downloading the file doing the
image metric and then uploading the file
again so that will take a little while
so we see a new element coming in let's
see if we get all the stuff alright okay
perfect so we have now the metadata
there which means our picture was
processed and first success okay awesome
so we have the first picture there let's
switch back to the slides
alright so we have our first mineral
minimal Viable Product right so we can
upload picture and I can display
pictures amazing and I can store some
metadata as well on it so now what if
our app grows right like a lot of people
thousands of people are starting to
upload cloudy pictures I said before
this is a very targeted app only for
cloudy pictures so now what I want to do
is I actually want to reduce some costs
in the beginning you saw I created a
bucket which is a multi-regional bucket
so the motor eating the original bucket
is actually our like most sophisticated
sort class that we have to reduce cost I
have actually different options and
storage classes that I can use there are
four storage classes available under the
cloud storage the multi-regional one is
the one that is distributed across two
regions which are at least a hundred
miles apart from each other and gives
you at the highest availability for your
needs now if you do data processing and
you want to actually process your data
close to where it is living then we
recommend to use a regional bucket
regional bucket is in one region is a
little bit cheaper and gives you a
little bit less of an availability SLA
now when it comes to archiving data we
have an airline and a cold line storage
class Nearline is pretty much if your
images or any kind of objects or
although they are not used with insert
days you can move them to near line then
it's cheaper actually to use near line
then have them storage on a regional or
multi-regional bucket now if you use
your data like less than once a year
then it's recommended to remove these
two cold line you still have the same
like persistency of the of your of your
data object and you still have the same
API s which is amazing but the prices
get go down
now one thing which is really important
to do with all these things automated or
in your application is something called
object lifecycle with the object
lifecycle what you can do is you can
define rules when object yet
automatically transition between the
storage classes so on my pocket I could
define rule if an object is older than
30 days please move it to in your line
if it is older than like 365 days or
although the 90 days please move it to
too cold line also can do that per
object I don't have to create a bucket
with a specific storage class you can do
that but you don't have to you can
actually change the storage class per
object so how does it look like you can
use it either with gsutil and do it
there or you can use a Java s you see
there to to move your object so I'm
gonna show that really quick how we
gonna do this here so I have a a second
application here which extracts some
more metadata so as you can see here the
same like setup code pretty much but
what I do is I'm reading the object and
then I'm using the SDK to get like EXIF
data out of it so now when this is done
what I want to do is actually I want to
move this object away so let's see or we
can do this so we can actually do like
here and then move the object
see how are we gonna do this
yeah
alright there is alright so basically I
take my object I just define in your
storage class built this and then say
like a cave and my metadata is processed
I just gonna move it to Nearline so I
gonna start this here as well and it's
gonna listen on my notification as well
so now this is a topic where
notifications have to have been sent
before so as you can see it starts
actually processing as well and it might
throw some errors because I have deleted
some object but it basically will
process in the background our our
objects so let's have a look if that is
actually working so what we can have
here is like we have our objects and in
time what you can see here is metadata
is showing up right so this gives me all
the EXIF data which I now can use to
search for incense or build a world map
where I can put all my pictures and if I
go to storage which I going to do here
you're going to go to my storage system
going to go to cloudy pictures I gotta
go to my Ross gonna see here and as you
can see my pictures actually now have
the storage system Nearline so even
though I created this factor the SM
multi-regional bucket I'm already moving
my story and my objects into a different
storage class which is really powerful
alright switching back alright so we
have that we have reduced our costs by
moving our objects and saving some cuts
there the next thing that I want to do
is enable a business model I want to I
want to generate some made some money
with this right so the app has been
control I've stored a lot of pictures
and now people have asked and and want
to actually like print and frame so by
frame and ship the pictures so I want to
n able this now if I want to do this
like I'm dealing with money and if I'm
dealing with money I need actually a
transexual directional system so I don't
want to do this with firestore because I
think my transactional guarantee is that
I have a fire store are not sufficient
for what I want to do so that's where
another storage system comes in and we
have a managed storage system it's
called for cloud SQL so cloud SQL is a
manager
EMS system where you can have MySQL or
Postgres and that also gives you things
like automatic updates you can do
backups you can do fail over so you can
do failover into other people clouds you
can do failover in to on-premise systems
things like that it is vertical scalable
so you can change your node size
throughout your life cycle of your
application and you have things like a
99.95 failsafe that's late so how do we
create a MySQL instance again very
straightforward cheat cloud SQL instance
great you give it a name you say the
tier which is basically the size that
you want to use in the region where this
cloud SQL instance is created next thing
is I want to talk to my cloud SQL MySQL
icon instance so what we provide is
actually an a proxy which automatically
authenticates you if you provided a
service service file so here what you
can see if you basically download to
your cloud SQL proxy and then you make
it executable and then you can run it
either locally or you can run it on your
TC instance or if you are familiar with
kubernetes which is a container
management system we can run it directly
in your pots as a sidecar to connect to
your cloud instance that's pretty much
straightforward
who here has done something with my
scale or any SQL database all right
amazing so this looks very familiar
relational schema I'm creating a
database and some tables in this case
I'm creating a user user table the cloud
aficionado by creating a balance table
which is basically my account balance
and I'm creating the transaction table
which shows me the history of the
transactions that have been done and
then I can do things like a like a
distributed console not a distributed
but its transaction which goes across
multiple tables so here you can see I
have a transaction that actually takes
some money from the balance table puts
it somewhere else in the balance table
and also writes in my transaction table
that this has been happened so it's
pretty much straightforward now the next
step is my app goes viral right so now
we've already
wanna do is we didn't want to need like
a scalability check so when I build my
cloud sleep cloudy pictures 3.0 I want
to be to be scalable for a large amount
of people so let's check cloud storage
is scalable cloud firestore or firestorm
on the firebase it's also scalable it is
a multi-tenant servers you don't have to
free provision any resources you
basically just use it with your
application and the more you use it will
scale with your needs amazing now cloud
SQL unfortunately it's one solution that
doesn't scale with your needs you can
scale it up to a certain point basically
the biggest VM that your cloud provider
or in our case who we cloud platform
provides you but if you run out of the
size of your of the biggest VM you kind
of stuck there are many many things that
you can do you can of course do charting
and blows like a distributed or DBMS but
it's very challenging and costs a lot of
time investment is very risky
so let's now where I want to plug into
out spanner cloudspinner is our
horizontally scalable and distributed
relational database system so you get
strong consistency with it and it scales
with your needs you can scale to
thousands of nodes and it scales
horizontally your schema permitting if
you want to learn a little bit more
about cloud spinner there's a shameless
plug at the at the bottom so if you
search for TI al about cloud spanner
you'll find a video series where I go
through some of the nitty gritties of an
amazing things that we do with cloud
spanner so let's recap what is the
portfolio under the Google Cloud storage
or Co who is our platform that we have
in terms of data and storage products so
we have covered cloud SQL
we have mentioned cloud spanner we have
mentioned cloud datastore firestore
there are a couple of others here on the
on the slide so if you use App Engine
you can use for into the App Engine
memcache if you use if you have a lot of
data which you want to search really
fast the process will be fast so if you
want to have like a very high
reads report read and write throughput
for non-relational data then we
recommend to use cloud BigTable
Oh cloud pigtailed has an age based
interface so you can connect it to your
likes park or things like that
then we also have a data warehouse
system manage data over our system which
is victory where you can go and load
relational data in and crunch terabytes
of data with bigquery all right so with
this I thank you very much for for your
attention if you have any questions
please feel free to walk up to the
microphones I'm happy to answer some of
your questions and please also if you
want to follow me on twitter under at
hasti rosti and I'm happy to answer any
kinds of questions of Twitter as well so
thank you very much for your attention
you I hope you enjoyed the talk and have
a good Coolio
[Music]
you